the broken pieces of you are adding up
buttercup
i have a theory hey that's my line
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
youtube's embodiment of chaos magic so
here we are
friends juan division is heading into
its epic episode 9 conclusion
after weeks of theorizing mostly right
some wrong
we finally know what happened we know
why we pretty much know how
honestly what we don't know is what
darcy's gonna binge once there's no more
show to watch
but i'm invested so now there's nothing
left except for the final showdown where
we learn the fates of all our favorite
characters
unless of course this whole show
resolves nothing and was instead a
prelude introducing us to agatha the new
vision 2.0
photon and the mini moths at which point
we're stuck waiting for resolution in
spider-man no way home in december
because that my friends is how you get
audiences to keep buying tickets to your
stuff in a post-end game world
one word cliffhangers but yeah at this
point it's pretty safe to say that
things are really going down in joysy
agnes excuse me agatha harkness
is an actual salem witch who infiltrated
the hex to steal wanda's powers which
means that wanda did indeed create the
imaginary sitcom reality
and mind enslaved the citizens of
westview after she was driven to her
psychological breaking point from
discovering
sword desecrating vision's body a
scenario seemingly orchestrated by
director haywood in an attempt to
reactivate vision's ai brain
why else would they only start
dissecting him like five years
after he died told you that guy was bad
news and that wanda had been to his
weird office confused well you're in
good company because so is wanda she
didn't even know her powers were
actual witchcraft up until this point as
agatha points out
wanda is the scarlet witch a legendary
being that uses chaos magic
which in the comics means that she was
influenced at birth by the dark elder
god oh god uh
chissan khan honestly there are way too
many consonants in a row here for that
word to have any real pronunciation oh
and uh if you didn't watch through the
credits sword apparently turned vision's
empty body into a super creepy white
terminator version what a twist
so yeah that's some heavy stuff kind of
makes you wish for the simpler days when
all we were talking about was cosmic
radiation and the birth of the
multiverse
but for everything that's now been
solved in the show
and everything that next week's finale
is going to address like ripping open
the multiverse and needing to team up
with monika
photon to take down the white vision i
think that there's one
massive dangling thread that may not pay
off now
may not pay off a year from now even but
will come up at some point in phase four
who knows maybe it'll be a post-credit
scene agnes loses and suddenly this big
reveal happens before the final credits
roll ready for this one
what if i told you the big secret of
this show the big
final reveal was that there's a third
witch
in west view and it all comes down to
flowers
all right this is about to get weird
even by wanda vision standard so lean in
all
hail hydra style my friends this is
gonna be our little secret so i'm sure
by now you've noticed that agatha and
wanda's magic slash
power slash telica whatsits are
color-coded when wanda does her finger
waggy zappy stuff it's always
shades of red well agatha is clearly big
into purple
that's also the color of those energy
vines that we saw in episode seven's
post-credit scene
and the color of all the flowers in
front of her house well it's
easy to overlook but agatha isn't the
only person with a green thumb here in
west view
in the same episode where agatha's true
identity is revealed and we get a good
look at her plants we also see wanda's
garden
and you guessed it the maximoff's roses
grow
red but wait a second here didn't roses
come up once before like
way back when the show was black and
white come to think of it the perfect
place to hide a color clue in plain
sight
goodness cody can't be as bad as you say
her roses bloom under penalty of death
yep it is easy to forget but when this
whole series began we were introduced
to dottie jones a character who gets a
big deal made out of her and an
even bigger deal made out of her flowers
dottie is the key to everything in this
town hiya dottie
your brothers are divine she was super
into her roses the show
really wanted you to remember that fact
about her she's set up to be a major
antagonist wanda
i've heard things about you you and your
husband
but i assure you i don't mean anyone any
harm
i don't believe you and she even gets
the show's first appearance of that
creepy line about children
all of this it's for the children for
the children
for the children but then nothing she
disappears for the rest of the show
dottie was apparently just a red herring
a false lead a chekhov's gun left
forgotten on the table
or at least that's what i thought until
episode seven you see right in the
middle of what we now know in hindsight
as a big confrontation between
all of our super powered female main
characters we get a cutaway to dottie
jones and her now
colorized bright yellow roses
all you do is lie so
could there be some hidden magic here
another witch
hiding in plain sight i mean if purple
flowers yield an
evil dark-haired witch with purple
powers and red flowers yield an angry
confused red-headed witch with scarlet
powers
it stands to reason that yellow flowers
could link up with a blonde-headed witch
with yellow
powers and wouldn't you know it but
that's exactly what you'll find in the
library of marvel comics characters
a blonde superhero sorceress whose magic
energy signature is usually yellow and
whose last
name is jones just like dottie theorists
let me introduce you to which number
three in west view
are canna jones and if those
similarities weren't convincing enough
they both
even have husbands named phil phil
do these earrings make me look fat
oh thank god oh and uh one other thing
arcana isn't just from the marvel
universe she comes from the marvel
multiverse so with her potentially being
important
let's talk a bit more about her arcana
was a member of squadron supreme a whole
team of characters who are
parodies of justice league members and
who live on an alternate reality earth
that basically exists for marvel writers
to dunk on their competitors at dc
there has been a bunch of different
versions and reboots of the squadron
over the years but what's interesting
about arcana maybe popping back up here
in the mcu
is that they're also getting a massive
new push in the comics you see marvel
just recently revealed that their big
summer events series will
and uh stummy if you've heard this one
zap the universe into an
alternate timeline where core heroes
never got their origins and the avengers
never formed in other words arcana and
the rest of our squadron supreme are
doing a sort of
what-if storyline where all the usual
suspects are decommissioned and this
group of randos are now the superheroes
on earth because no one else is there to
get the job done
now you know what you're thinking
superheroes blinked away into an
alternate timeline you're gonna tell me
this is another wand thing right
no of course not don't be ridiculous i
mean
how predictable do you think these get
right geez guys give me some slack
wasn't
wanda it was her dad magneto well it was
half him anyway you see in the comics it
was really the result of combining the
subconscious minds of magneto and
charles xavier into a single entity
basically professor x and his best
friend of me made a mind baby named
onslaught and it broke the marvel
universe into different lunch periods
for a few months
so is that what wand division is
building up to absolutely not
but maybe something similar if in fact
marvel is suddenly having squadron
supreme members like arcana of all
characters pop their heads out
consider this what if we've all been
thinking about this backwards almost
everyone who's theorized about wanda's
future role in the mcu myself included
has focused on her upcoming role in
multiverse of madness as this indicator
that she'll be involved in making the
marvel cinematic universe bigger and
crazier maybe by bringing in the x-men
changing powers around
expanding genres whatever but from what
we've seen of her actions
and her state of mind throughout one
division bigger worlds are the opposite
of what she's looking for one division
has been all about how this would-be
scarlet witch has retreated from the
ideas of friendship and community and
found
family even reality itself she is living
in her own head she is
living inside of nostalgia literally
building walls and safe spaces in order
to protect
herself now the show is clearly
demonstrating that this is unhealthy and
self-destructive but in the bigger
picture
she's also fundamentally turned against
the foundations of the mcu's basic
philosophy i don't know if you've
noticed this but each and every one of
these films has reinforced the idea of
being a team player
sacrificing for the greater good forming
found families
crossing and even ultimately eliminating
the concept of borders and separations
everything being connected is not only
marvel studios strategy
and brand it's also their philosophical
ideology but as it concerns poor mrs
maximoff over in westview if she loses
her family again it'll push
wanda to go full onslaught and blast the
mcu into fragments potentially trapping
individual
franchises in worlds where avengers and
guardians never teamed up or worlds
where
shield never unfroze steve rogers or
more likely based on the upcoming movie
slate worlds where thor
is suddenly jane foster as confirmed by
the early plot of thor love and thunder
or one where tony stark never helped
upgrade peter parker where he's left to
fend for himself alongside other famous
spider people from the past
struggling to find his way home they've
already practically confirmed that wanda
can absolutely do this even before we
knew about the apparently limitless
power of the chaos magic this appears
most
clearly in episode 7's fake commercial
act break for the antidepressant
medication nexus
a unique antidepressant that works to
anchor you back to your reality
or the reality of your choice at this
point in the series all the other
commercial breaks have been explained
the toaster was tony stark's bomb like
we predicted the hydra soap was the mine
stone
also kind of like we predicted the shark
eating yo magic yogurt was agatha
looking to consume
wanda's powers leaving her an empty
dried-out husk the only one left
unexplained is that final nexus
commercial and that's
because it's not looking backwards but
rather is the only one looking ahead
at what's to come specifically nexus is
a clear reference to the comic's nexus
of all realities which acts as a hub
between the different regions of the
multiverse and
also to nexus beings superhumans that
are powerful enough to manipulate the
order and shape of those
realities i'll give you one guess as to
who's a nexus being
wanda guess who made that distinction a
group of cosmic bureaucrats named the
time
variance authority not ringing any bells
well don't worry it shouldn't
yet but get used to hearing the name
there are the guys who are almost
certainly giving orders to the god of
mischief in the upcoming
loki show again worlds connecting worlds
in a shattered universe and a fractured
universe of course could eventually be
triumphantly recombined in ways that
would make reintroducing mutants
inhumans x-men deadpool everyone from
netflix minus iron fist and
all manner of reboots much much simpler
but more importantly would give phase 4
a chance to reaffirm how important all
that
family and connection stuff is to the
mcu and how lost
all the characters were without it while
also doing a bunch of meta satirical
dunking on certain other superhero
franchises that
always go the solo superhero route huh
which obscure marvel team
suddenly seems to be all over the place
again it was arcana
all along but hey that's
just a theory a film theory
and one other thing for weeks now fans
of the series have been buzzing about
paul bettany's tease of a special guest
star that's yet to appear on the show
about which he'd only say that they're a
performer that he's really wanted to
work with and has never had the chance
to before
the guesses on this have encompassed
basically every actor who has ever
played a superhero but has never shared
a scene with vision from patrick stewart
as professor x to hugh jackman as
wolverine
well we don't know who the character is
or if it'll be a marvel character at all
but we do have ourselves a theory about
who that mystery actor will be when they
show up
none other than the disney legend dick
van dyke you see
episode 8 revealed that the reason
wanda's magic mental breakdown happy
place looks like ancient american
sitcoms is that like a lot of real-life
immigrants of her generation she learned
english in part
watching classic american tv shows and
formed a powerful nostalgic connection
to their idealized version of american
suburbia and while we saw dvds or clips
from almost every series one division
has made references to
only one was explicitly highlighted and
named as
wanda's absolute favorite the dick van
dyke show which not only formed the
point of reference for wandavision's
first episode the series creators
actually brought in the still very much
alive 95 year old comedy star
as a consultant to help them get their
classic tv feel
just right so yeah i'm calling my shot
with this one the big final guest
appearance of the show will be dick van
dyke as far as who they're gonna have in
play
don't really know think you can pull off
a submariner speedo